when Caliban first steps onto the screen
and Logan it's impossible to tell who's
under that killer costume but after he
took off his bandana and goggles a
little Bell of recognition probably went
off in your head there's something
familiar about the photosensitive mutant
tracker
Caliban is played by British writer
comedian and actor Stephen Merchant but
he's had quite a career long before he
landed the choice role of Charles Xavier
caretaker so where on earth have we seen
this guy before
merchants began his career doing
stand-up and sketch comedy before
meeting Ricky Gervais so in 1997 when
Gervase gave him a job at London's XFM
radio station the duo hosted a cult
weekend radio show for several years
introducing the world to their future
podcast co-host karl Pilkington
you could have a line so I goes lovely
ladies but middle ear pieces come open
is here and later teamed up as
co-creators of one of the most
critically acclaimed comedies of all
time the office in addition to creating
the comedy classic merchant also had a
small appearance in series 2 showing up
as one of Gerrits friends nicknamed the
odd monster of a guy because that is
just sequences in 500 the age of five so
that's what makes with it bulbs merchant
interface both served as executive
producers on the American version of the
show and wrote the episode the convict
which means merchant helped give the
world prison Mike what was the food like
in prison gruel sandwiches gruel omelets
not only gruel and for that the world is
eternally grateful
in 2005 merchant and Gervase followed up
the office with another acclaimed cringe
comedy extras the series follows Gervase
is a desperate background actor trying
to break into the spotlight merchant
places incompetent agents to be too
dazed to realize they're eight hours
ahead there behind are they yes explains
kwang-ho merchants performance scored in
the Best Actor Prize at the British
Comedy Awards that same year merchant
interface wants the popular Ricky
Gervais show podcast which was later
reimagined as a cartoon for HBO even
caveman little pom-pom why don't why
Lodi why in 2011 the two reunited for
life's too short a series based around
the fictionalized life of work Davis the
actor who played wicket the Ewok in
Return of the Jedi and in 2010 merchant
interface produced and appeared in an
Idiot Abroad a documentary series
featuring karl Pilkington being sent to
exotic locations often against his will
in 2007 merchant made his big-screen
debut and Edgar Wright's Hot Fuzz
alongside Simon Pegg and appeared very
briefly again that same year with Pegg
in Run Fatboy run in 2009 merchant had a
quick cameo in the Ricky Gervais selm
the invention of lying but his profile
got much higher the following year when
merchant showed up alongside Dwayne
Johnson and Disney's Tooth Fairy playing
the rocks otherworldly caseworker since
then merchant appeared briefly in
cemetery junction which he also wrote
and directed with Gervase played third
fiddle to Jason Sudeikis and Owen Wilson
and the Farrelly Brothers flop Hall Pass
and shared the screen with Halle Berry
in the dreadful movie 43 among a
smattering of other small roles and of
course if we didn't catch any of those
movies you may have run across merchants
while holding a controller video game
fans could never forget his role as the
sweet then sadistic Wheatley from Portal
2 on the sea to which like to take a
little back and not just because I'm
stranded in space okay I know who you
are mate merchant finally struck out in
the zone in 2013 with HBO's hello ladies
the short-lived series followed the
character of Stuart Pritchard in
Englishman who's moved to Los Angeles in
the hopes of becoming a big-time ladies
man of course Stewart isn't as debonair
as he thinks instead he's a kind of
socially awkward jerk who lies about a
handicapped friend being a war vet so he
can worm his way inside a swanky Club
merchants filled the show with moments
from his actual love life using his most
pitiful dating stories to create some
truly awkward themes when as in Roe
versus Wade and famous case about a
woman's rights they know what it is
there's no need to bring up a book do we
need to Hello ladies only lasted one
season before HBO pulled the plug
although merchant was able to give
viewers closure with a story ending
movie merchan has appeared on Comedy
Central's drunk history three times
always playing an American president
he's donned a top hat twice to play
brahim Lincoln as well as sporting a wig
for the part of George Washington the
guy doesn't even speak English so he
says
blah blah blah it only makes sense that
merchants played two of America's taller
presidents but even though Washington
stood at 6-2 and Lincoln measured up at
six for the six foot seven Englishmen
still hasn't beat in 2015 merchants
helped create the show lip-sync battle
it all started in 2013 when merchants
was talking with the offices John
Krasinski about what Krasinski should do
for his upcoming appearance on Late
Night with Jimmy Fallon and they decided
on a lip-syncing contest
Fallon reused the skit multiple times
with merchants once coming aboard to
face off against Fallon and Joseph
gordon-levitt soon the concept made its
way over to Spike where it became
lip-sync battle the lanky merchant even
once donned a crop top and a pair of
chaps for his take on Christina
Aguilera's dirty
[Music]
if you still don't recognize merchant
maybe his appearance in the most popular
sitcom in America will jog your memory
in 2015 he appeared as math teacher Dave
Gibbs on the CBS smash Big Bang Theory
dating Amy following her breakup with
Sheldon
Dave turns out to be a Sheldon super fan
asking fanboy questions about his
favorite theoretical physicist rather
than actually having a real conversation
with his date but all's well that ends
well since Dave helped Sheldon and Amy
get back together encouraging the
socially awkward scientists to patch
things up hiss are you brilliant fool
thanks for watching click the looper
icon and subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]